my name is Peter Santaniello and I make
videos around the world but for the
first time I'm showing my home country
America in this video series my
Ukrainian wife and I travel through
Northern California to places most
foreigners and even Americans don't know
about we will show you USA culture
through the combination of an outsider's
and a locals perspective join us
on a road trip through a very diverse
often misunderstood and stunningly
beautiful land it's really cool when you
come back to your country after being
gone for a long time
we're in this place called Sea Ranch and
they have all these homes I think I
think a lot of them or are for rent but
they have this very cool modern styles
imagine eating at this table and having
that view oh my god this must be a
fortune
so beautiful huh
it says there's a sign there that says
baby seals lay out on these rocks here
this place is called the Sea Ranch
it's a massive planned community that
spans ten miles along the pacific coast
highway with roughly 1,800 homes
this is modernist architecture way ahead
of its time the first structure was
built in 1964 what's different about the
Sea Ranch versus any other planned
community I've seen is the way the homes
blend into the natural landscape all of
the wood is unpainted there are no
foreign species of plants nobody waters
the grass there are no street lights to
interfere with the Starlight this is by
far the coolest housing development I've
ever seen
what's that
the ego for the ha
this is a very interesting place called
Fort Ross and Fort Ross is a Russian
settlement on the California coast and
so the Russians when they went they went
east sort of as the Americans were going
west their expanding territory they
occupied Alaska was Russian and they
needed wheat they needed fruit they
needed food for Alaska so where they go
they went down the California coast
and set up this settlement what they
also found here were seals and seals
that were super valuable for wealthy
people in Moscow on the rest of Europe
so they actually killed seals here and
brought the pills back through Alaska
through Russia into Europe but it's very
cool to be in this part of the country
of the US and all of a sudden stumble
upon Russian influence and maybe a
little bit of a shocker for you entire
little Slavic world California let's
check it out here's the settlement well
I've actually dug a well in the
countryside of Ukraine it's a process
shallow by shovel
oh yeah sure yeah it's water down there
you want to go to church babe I know you
love church there's an Orthodox Church
for you been in there it's cold it's
cold at the bottom dome ravit Thalia
which means the rulers home so these
were would they say the first glass
windows in California that's what the
video said first glass windows in
California how crazy is that quite
inspirational I can imagine a much
better winter existence here and in cold
Siberia Alaska or Moscow the fortress
wall
massive eucalyptus tree and these aren't
native to California they're from
Australia smell the smell these leaves
Smith very fragrant huh yeah they've
taken over the California coast I love
them they're quite spectacular they get
huge not alike
[Music]
Dungeness crab
first clam chatter experience
[Music]
okay now now we're gonna take a little
little detour here and check out this
place Russian house number one what's
going on here
it's like help your own food
hello Russell kosher and across the
street miss Italia Ukrainian flag so
cool because we live in Ukraine sitios
Naruto they've been here before this so
what's the story what's going on with
this Russian restaurant and the you like
the Russian house is the Ukrainian flag
and they're fresh off the boat so you
know it's just super interesting we're
in California right on the coast
oh really
it got ripped by the wind oh there was
it was like a Muslim were there or the
Soviet Union books
Oh people will be pissed here at
Americans like Oh
the freedom of the speech you know yeah
what do you sell at sea of uh yes
succulents everything school
what's going on just don't confuse us
like it's almost unbelievable I think
there was the Soviet flag before it was
like this Orion yeah and this lady had
this shock from Ukrainian flag
here's another tus she owns this and she
rents to them yeah maybe it's marketing
you know like smart work it's enough to
see the
the interesting story there's got to be
a story a big story we don't know about
doing a time-lapse of this plant I don't
know the name of I gotta get it
absolutely
[Music]
um stretched extended ready to hit that
record button
so when I lived here I'd ride my bike
almost every day over this bridge up
that hillside
and back into the city and that's the
coolest thing about this city San
Francisco is the fusion of urban in
nature and so you can just rip out super
easy and get into beautiful nature
living in the stands what I miss the
most by far living here I don't miss the
prices that's for sure
so they also have a painting crew on
this bridge all the time so they paint
from one side to the other and when they
get to that other side I forget years
later they start back and it's a
continuous process of painting this
bridge there are also a lot of suicides
a lot of people jump off this bridge and
kill themselves is not reported because
suicides are not reported in the US I
don't know if that applies to other
places because there's that groupthink
a fact that happened you know some
people get inspired by Seuss
you asked me is is Kiev Ukraine better
than San Francisco yeah
and natural beauty hell no obviously not
not even comparison
nature no way
but as far as like a nice city to walk
around in the center and the parks where
everyone just sort of hangs I'd say
Kiev's better
amazing huh these cargo ships out here
are most I'm going to China and you
constantly see this Bay you know there's
a ship coming in going under the bridge
so for those that are much younger or to
another geopolitics the US and the
Soviet Union huge rivals and so along
the shores along the shores of
California are these missile launch pads
and they're most of them are
decommissioned I'm sure they're plenty
that are here still functioning we just
don't see them but here's an example
we're gonna go up to here of one of
these places where well at the Soviets
came here as a way to protect the shores
of the u.s. crazy to think that stuff
wasn't that long ago
these pelicans so there it is the Golden
Gate and then this military site and now
we have skateboarders which is way
cooler than guns and missiles Nana wants
some pictures guaranteed I have to get
on this picture program the iconic
Golden Gate at sunset Shah is gonna
happen right now oh yeah I spilled it at
the end
[Applause]
[Music]
what were you saying pelicans and the
sound of the foghorn hear that sound
that's because you can super foggy this
boats come in and they know where the
rocks are
[Applause]
this is the new mega money here mega
money Jack your C of Twitter most
beautiful park in the city in my opinion
it's got a little bit of everything
[Music]
movement started here
whatever goes
[Music]
you